I I definitely like Islam have a lot of
Muslim friends I like that they they
don't get pushed around like you know I
like Christianity too but the guys have
let themselves get pushed around and
mock too much and Islam doesn't do that
I think a lot of people they have this
narrative that's been spun by the media
by the zionists the Muslims are
terrorists and all this but in reality
you've been to those countries the
hospitality is massive these they all
have big family networks they uh they
take care of each other you know I've
been Islamic country people invited me
to their home for tea they're so
Hospital yeah so so people they you know
people on online are telling me like oh
muss hate you why are you treating this
like I've actually been to these
countries they they don't hate me they
love me they treat me great so they're
going to Mecca after so if I convert
I'll go with them yeah you have to
convert to go it's funny cuz he's
Christian my filmer and like he couldn't
even go he was able we went I love to go
to Mecca but it's like you know the best
place in the world it's genuinely like
the the best experience I support the
death penalty for breaking into cars and
tearing off catalo converters and that's
not clickbait and here's why we had a
plumber schedule to come out because
there's some massive flooding happening
and we needed him to replace some pipes
he's not able to too so we had to get a
water pump to pump it out which I was
able to do but that meant that I didn't
have to go to work but since I have a
laptop job what's the big deal well the
the big deal is I remember people like
my dad were at the financial margins
could not afford to miss a day of work
right people can't afford to miss a day
of work that creates a whole load of
Downstream problems how you going to pay
your rent how you going to pay your
mortgage how going to buy your groceries
let's talk about the plumber his car was
broken into dashboard was torn up he's
going to miss two or three days of work
he's self-employed that means no money
two or three days that means his bills
get pushed back why so some drug addict
working for the cartels could steal
that's the choice we're making that's
the choice we're making I used to think
it was barbaric the code of hamurabi and
you'd read about Saudi Arabia
decapitating criminals and you would
think how barbaric and I realize now why
they do it because you either execute
criminals for property crime crimes
which by the way would end the crimes
overnight because they would get the
point so you either execute them or you
just let people suffer because what
happened to me today is a minor
inconvenience honestly whatever I'm I'm
not not even a big deal to me in the
grand scheme of things but to the
plumber it's a big deal the people like
how I grew up is a big deal to millions
of people the tens of million PE tens of
million of people it's a big deal so
we're making a choice and the choice is
that we're going to let everyone suffer
so that people can commit crimes and oh
it's just a property crime no it isn't
it's a human rights violation because
you're stealing people's ability to work
so we got to bring it back death penalty
no no irony here no cap bring it back
what do you got there man let's see what
kind of pen you have there oh man you
shouldn't have done that now when you
cut off the the hand of the the thief is
it like that or is it like
this I'll tell you it's not important
how to but what's important is what
people think of it now this is the thing
now you know all jokes aside you know
this a very important topic that we're
trying to cover but you know what some
people make a mockery of this beautiful
way of life the way of life that's from
the creator of the heavens and earth so
we want to clear up the many
misconceptions you know Islam is about
Mercy you know Islam is a merciful
religion but some would try to have
people think that it's the antithesis
that's a barbaric way of life and we're
going to start off with explaining in
context people say you know what Islam
is just about chopping the head chopping
the hands and then you got chopped up
meat to eat
so let's talk about this is that what
Islam is all about chopping people up
absolutely not as a matter of fact on
the contrary God Mighty actually tells
us how to prevent this from happening by
the
uh meaning that inside fear into them
why to prevent them from fighting to
start off with to actually save the
Bloodshed to actually do this to give
him options other than having to fight
and believe it or not this is one of the
options when people think that Islam is
barbaric by the cutting the hand they
only see the end result they don't look
at the uh all the root cause analysis
look at the uh prevention is better than
cure method they look at just that but
if you look deeply you'll find out that
Islam is trying to prevent this from
happening by telling you if you do this
we will do that so it's scaring you off
don't do it and you'll find out the case
is that Islam looks at a bigger picture
the bigger picture of the community for
example if
everyone is protected from one person
meaning the thief it is a way of life in
Islam it says the good of all proceeds
the good of one so you should be happy
about this but the idea behind it is
people only look for the fish for faults
or look for certain things but under the
normal uh human being Natural Instinct
that they want some things we all have
whims and desires but we have to control
it there is a checks and Bounds to
things if you don't have a fear of God
almighty okay if you don't have the love
for God Almighty the same ideas that we
tell you if you cross the red light we
will put a we slap you with a fine so
there is something there that love and
fear you have to have the combination of
both not just love other uh people that
try to preach it's not the case human
beings have to have both so the same
thing you get rewarded if you don't do
this and if you do this you will get
punished but the idea behind it is that
now we're uh saving uh you know this man
from himself not just everybody else
same idea with uh the bigger context the
bigger picture the community which looks
for in Islam is that prevention is
better than cure don't do this otherwise
you would and you'll see the statistics
alhamdulillah that is much lower than
anybody else as you will see in the
western Society you'll see a repetitive
people uh you know do certain crimes and
you come back and plead insanity and
come back and do it again and taxpayers
pay the same thing and you'll see they
do the same thing for the kids they do
do that and they keep doing it for not
so we say Islam says no stop we have
consequences to protect everyone else in
the community so can you say this is a
strong deterrent and when this is
implemented and can we just back it up
because we know that Islam the way of
life that was lived by Abraham Moses
Jesus peace be upon him because Islam
calls to surrender and submit to the
creator of the heavens and earth not a
man or a monkey but the creator of all
that exists and a Muslim is one who does
Islam so when this complete system God's
system from Creator the Divine systs
implemented isn't it true that there
wouldn't be people who were for instance
uh poor you have the zakat there'll be
justice so you wouldn't have all these
criminals out here you know robbing
stealing looting can we back it up to
that absolutely this is a one way to
look at what Allah subhah waala put
Justice into this at the time
of is actually lifted this H this this
rule was not was actually invalid
because there was not enough for people
to eat so we say there are rules and
regulations if everyone has enough for
sustenance and Provisions for them to
feed themselves and feed their families
now you're actually uh going to
transgress on others rights so we say
you know if you see a beautiful flower
enjoy it you want to smell it great but
do you want to cut it we say no stop you
see that's the when we say now taking
somebody else's Freedom you teaching you
to take the easy way out so you become
you become a thief and so on this is
even uh saying that even went to a man
says if you don't give that man that
works for you enough money to be able to
live we will cut your hand off that's to
the employer to the boss you better pay
him right corre absolutely so we have
all these checks of bounds in order for
you to prevent this from happening and
everything is provided for you and if
you're not having a job the system looks
after you and after all these things
that we will look after you under
circumstances you decide to go on your
own take somebody else's right and
decide to go you will pay the
consequences it's human nature so is
this also more for the the plotter
planner the schemer the person now who's
going to break in your home and he knows
that you have a diamond watch he knows
that you have a bank Row in your safe
and he puts your family in Jeopardy your
children and your wife because if you
see him now he gets the gun out out of
fear he might kill you so is this for
that person that broken your home almost
maybe possibly rape your wife to steal
your life savings is that the person
we're talking about absolutely I mean
Islam is Justice established Justice
upon everything including uh criminal uh
offenses for example if we tell someone
that this man that you just talked about
came to your home you know raped your
wife uh you know uh took your daughter
away and took your money and and and all
that if I tell you what would you do and
do this you would cut him to pieces you
would kill them apart says no Islam is
more merciful than that we will just cut
their hand we will ask him what hand did
you cut with and it would be this hand
that we would cut according to his
testimony and of course we understand
that this specific fact that om again
going back to him the woman came to ask
him to Pardon her son because he stole
he was caught stealing he says W by by
God Almighty is not the first time his
told because God Almighty will not have
exposed them from the first time so God
Almighty gives you chances and chances
and chances say if we caught early it's
preventive as opposed of you going up on
the ladder being even worse of a a thief
and a criminal and God Almighty give you
too many chances but when you get caught
that means it's better for you because
God Almighty says that in the Quran we
will give him a taste of punishment in
this life before the taste of punishment
Hereafter so they may come back and if
you do it expiates your sin if every
penalty is done here in this life as if
you've done none you're clear this is
amazing yeah because that's an important
point it's a very important Point like
if somebody just stole your keys to your
house or your cell phone with all your
uh contacts and then you ask the person
right now in his raids like what would
you do to this per you caught him that's
a violation of your right something
private something that you hold valuable
that person like you said would want to
now you know have his way if he was the
judge but Islam is even more merciful
we're going to take a break and I I got
so many more questions to ask you about
this when we come back here on the de
show sit
tight go to my room lock the door
prostrate and cry saying God you know me
better than myself show me the right way
and I will not look back I will leave
everything
behind Allah is our creator and he
creates everything and he gives
intelligent to
people as muhamad pleas be upon Muhammad
is one of the last Messengers s from
[Music]
God back here on the dean show with shik
Allah thank you very much for being with
us here on the dean show pleasure thank
you for having me you have a lot of
experience you're the director of the
Islamic Circle Center of Canada and also
public relations director for Mercy
Mission so you have a lot of experience
with this with dealing with these type
of questions and we're trying to create
a better understanding with the not yet
Muslims those brothers that are brothers
in humanity is that right absolutely now
tell us just before we go on to the next
misconception and putting things in
context you know tell me what you think
about this because we know that you know
all these rules and regulations are from
the Divine and there's great wisdom
behind them any logical person who looks
at it in context he'll see this makes
sense so the the criminal he's plotting
and planning and he's putting aside
money he sees The Big Heist I'll make a
million here but he's putting like five
six S8 $10,000 away for for the the
attorney hoping that you know if I get
caught I'll beat the rap on a
technicality I'll go ahead and get
probation so do you think now is this
known that when you know that look this
is the consequence of you breaking in
someone's home robbing a bank that this
is coming on it's getting amputated
you're not going to do this absolutely
it's again something called the SDI
Strategic Defense Initiative because
this will happen if you do then that
means don't mess with me this because of
the consequence you'll pay because
that's what God Almighty says this Allah
says this this retribution do taking a
penalty this keeps you alive keep you a
way of a good life so the idea behind it
is best for you not against you so if we
think about even the sisters when they
start complaining about you know why
cover and why wear the hijab among the
other you know misconception that women
are oppressed and we force them to we
the hijab and tell the sister the same
thing you know when you were young that
now you have what it takes uh you're you
bous voluptuous and beautiful and you
have what it takes to fla your your
stuff now uh you grow old you don't have
what it takes anymore there's a younger
sister comes in to uh now being testing
your husband and so on so we say the
same idea we are now protecting others
from you now when you're young but when
you grow old we're protecting you from
everybody else same idea with the thief
we're protecting not one person we're
protecting everybody else from one and
that's the methodology of the of Islam
to look after the good of all as opposed
of the good of one and the Serene
security of the community when God's
system Islam total and complete
submission to the one Gody creator of
the all that exists when his system was
implemented through history were there
people now when this was implemented
walking around with chopped off hands no
actually the believe it or not this uh
these things are very rarely done very
rare very rarely done uh actually these
things that they have to have witnesses
and and the witnesses come and they and
they don't say the same thing they will
be also flogged for this so Islam makes
these things are very strict very tight
so not everybody else can claim that
they've done done things they have to be
caught with the evidence and so on and
convicted so these all these six chicks
and Bounds to make sure that uh justice
established in the time of Al Talib as a
matter of fact even though he was the
head of the state at the time the kif
the
successor he claimed that somebody else
stole uh something that belonged to him
that was given to Prophet by Prophet
Muhammad may peace upon him this we know
the story but even though he was a
Jew the system defended
the rules and regulations of Islam they
say that do you have any Witnesses and
everybody knew that this was his but
they did not see the ACT nor that was
taken and nobody else he says I have my
son he says you taught us that the
branch will not testify for the root do
you have anybody else he says no he says
this belongs to the Jew so the Jewish
man even though he was in a Muslim State
being judged again the The Head of the
State and the the judge was a Muslim he
says I can't believe this in this state
the judge rules with fairness and
Justice and he became a Muslim because
Islam established Justice we're not
after anyone for a specific reason so
it's not for a Snicker bar you're hungry
now and you need some to feed your
family and you go you know get some food
someone's crop a corn you know some
bread some barley and you eat now your
hands off absolutely not that's that's
not about that that's not okay that's
really really deep because when you know
that this is coming off why are you a
criminal in the first place huh
absolutely yeah so you should be living
a righteous life and this is a deterrent
being content with what you got you
content what you got so this is really a
strong deterrent cuz when you know it's
coming out you're going to stay away
from hurting innocent people and you're
going to stay away from robbing banks
robbing individuals and it's amazing
okay let's move on this is a a very
important point because you hear this a
lot now you'll also hear and you'll see
this again I mean we want to reach out
to the politicians and I hope that they
the Muslims will pass this on to the
politicians they can see what Muslims
are really about because we have
qualified individuals such as yourself
explaining Islam not the car mechanic or
Peter Jing's king or whoever else is out
there that has a twisted understanding
you took years to understand took years
to understand this Quran the verbaan
word of God so when people take one
verse and they'll say kill those for
instance who are not Muslims the
infidels or whatnot you know is is this
the same thing that someone who's a
terrorist who goes kills innocent people
he'll take a verse to justify are they
doing the same thing to create division
amongst people certainly one way do it
but before we go on I'd like to say that
this poor slave of Allah is learning as
we are so thank you for your V of
confidence but we're all learning first
the Infidel the word infidel itself is
not really the proper translation for
this CF the word CF comes in a different
understandings even for a a peasant like
a a farmer or something that covers
meaning cover the truth meaning that the
one and only God on so on or those who
disbelieve in the message doesn't
necessarily mean so but the Quran
addresses the Christians and Jews in a
very way to say that oh people of the
book and everybody knows when God
Almighty says the people of the book are
the Christian and Jews then kill him
that even though that the under the word
c meaning this believe in the message of
Muhammad may peace be upon him or the
Oneness of God it's a different story
but it's not accordingly infidels but
the people when they say that we have to
kill them because the the the Quran says
that and unfortunately they use the cut
and paste Theory but if they look before
it and they look after it you'll find
out the biggest the context of the whole
verse and and we know that Allah subhana
wa tala mentioned in the
Quran it was given permission for those
who are being fought those who are being
killed they were being oppressed so what
does Islam do it says defend yourself
you have the right to defend yourself so
they says these are the one that being
killed not uh every thumb they can hay
and God Almighty also revealed these
things with the mush of qur those the
idol worshippers not for everybody those
who are killing you they were driving
you out of your home killing your family
stealing your land taking your a worldly
possession you have the right to defend
yourself it is not being an oppress
aggressive you're being a defensive so
of course that these people say that
because you're not a Muslim I have to
kill you the amazing thing is that the
Quran gives us a uh permission to marry
from man to marry from a Christian woman
or or a Jewish woman according to the
opinion of some of the scholars and
their circumstances could you imagine
now my wife is a Christian or my wife is
a is a Jewish woman say I love you honey
but I can't be your
friend that's another one yeah you can't
be friends yes or I love you honey but I
have to kill you yeah can you imagine
that is absolutely makes no sense
whatsoever so people that do cut and
paast Theory they translate it according
to their own whims and desires their own
hidden agendas absolutely have no place
in Islam No Place inam is there a verse
in the Quran and can you elaborate on
this the translation of the meaning
because we have the an is the rebating
word of God it's tamper free tamper
proof preserved and memorized by
millions that's another
topic that it says that God has not
forbade you from showing kindness to
those who have not fought you or driven
you out of your lands talk to us about
this absolutely in you go back and
you'll find out that God Almighty says
that it's a beautiful verse the meaning
of the interpretation God Almighty
forbids you not to be kind and just and
I'll have to come back to that word to
explain it for those who do not fight
you in your religion and do not kick you
out of your home so let us go find out
the conditions what are the conditions
if people leave Muslims to worship God
Almighty and don't kick me out of your
home of my home I will have to be more
than kind and more than just I have to
go back to the Arabic word in order for
me to translate this properly and I say
at least if you go just on the apparent
meaning of the verse if someone tells
you listen I'll leave you to worship God
on uh on your the way you you want to
worship God and I won't kick you your
home home is that too much to ask that's
a minimum requirement for any human
being for their own rights so let's go
back to the Arabic text and say find out
says it say the word in Arabic is has a
connotation the relationship between a
father the parents and the children and
they were supposed to be extremely kind
to them and the second one is the is
that means higher than the Arabic word
is meaning just and fair but is actually
higher sometimes it's mistranslated so
all we ask is that being very simple
leave us to worship God in the way that
we were so commanded to do in the proper
way not killing the innocent and so on
I'll come back to that if there's a
chance and do not kick us out of your
home our homes we will treat you more
better than our fathers and mothers and
we'll be more than fair with you not too
much to ask I hope that you're getting
to benefit I surely am and those who are
sincere who want to know the truth you
come to the right place sit tight for
more here on the dean
show and with good deeds uh we will find
that good breeds
good clear out your mind and your heart
of hatred mhm and preconceived
notions racism and nationalism because
you cannot have anything inside of you
that's like that against people and
still be successful
with back here on the dean show and we
cover the chopping of the hands we put
things in context
and it's not for a Snicker par this is
for as a deterrent to keep those people
who are barbaric from hurting the
innocent people any person who has a
sound mind can see that this makes sense
so tell us now we talked about also and
continue on where this misconception of
you know oh we're infidels and you're
Muslims and kill us and all this which
by the way I if you study historically I
mean the Quran is in the Arabic so when
you translate English just because it's
there it doesn't the author committ a
mistake but this wasn't this true that
this word from studying was coined
actually by the Christian Crusaders who
they called those Muslims infidels who
weren't of the same Faith so now it's
being pointed at us and you covered that
that it's not the proper translation so
continue on from there the part about
killing
non-muslims okay and also the friendship
between non-muslims and Muslims
absolutely but first we have to say that
we don't blame everyone for having the
misconceptions because we didn't maybe
reach out or build Bridges or educate or
raise awareness or all they know about
Islam is uh Allah abbar you know they
watch a certain uh you know News Channel
or anything else that they also have
their own hidden agenda and they don't
portray the the proper message out or
they have people that mislead or
misrepresent Islam to be the you know if
it bleeds it leads and their own whims
and desires and having the word
association with it and that's another
topic but now to continue on with what
we're talking about today let's go to
another verse in the Quran that Allah
subhana wa tala mentioned in the Quran I
don't have enough time to to go into
everything but at
least and so on till the end of the
verse in Arabic I'm quoting in Arabic
because Quan is mean the translation
meaning of the interpretation in summary
if you kill one innocent Soul as if he
killed the whole humanity and if you if
you save one innocent Soul as if you
saved the whole Humanity but the beauty
of this verse again going back to the
Arabic text
The Scholar
says the word ISS Soul Spirit human
being person and it's not this not
doesn't have Al Alam meaning it is not
definite it's not he didn't say if you
kill a Muslim Soul he didn't he said any
Soul a Muslim Christian Jew Buddhist
Hindu agnostic any soul that doesn't
even believe in God is off limits and
that's what the scholar says God
Almighty says any soul as if you killed
the whole Humanity that's how severe the
punishment is in the sight of God and if
you save any Soul as if you save those
the whole Humanity the beauty about it
is that Islam also hold you accountable
for a soul of an animal the prophetic
tradition is authentic when a woman will
be going to the Hellfire not eternally
of course those who believe in one God
will not eternally go to Hellfire if
they of course repent before they die or
they did not they will pay the price and
come back just to clarify the context
now the Hadith says that because she TI
her did not feed the cat or let her go
out to eat from the sustenance of God
there she died so we are held
accountable for the spirit or the soul
of a cat and a Hadith the prophetic
tradition says the woman or a man both
says that they quench The Thirst of a
dog they will be going to heaven for
that simple fact so don't you think if
we're held accountable for a spirit for
a cat or a dog we will not be held
accountable for the spirit of a human
being because the proof is in the Quran
God Almighty
says we have elevated or honored or
leveled the higher in that human being
above all you see so in that Essence we
have to put the context straight so in
order for us to say that you know what I
can kill a human being with no
consequences there is a major
consequences even in state of war the
state of War we don't have anything
called collateral damage even if he kill
an innocent person while in the state of
War even by mistake you still have to
pay a ransom there is every human being
every soul is accountable and since
we're talking on Wars I'll close with
the Ten Commandments of war and please
compare the 10 commandments of War again
no connotation or the command in Islam
absolutely it has no connotation for the
Ten Commandments that is known but this
is just of the ethic and the moral
conduct of the Muslim Army going to
fight and please compare these 10 with
what you know about Islam from any other
type of media Outlet the this is the
commands from Prophet Muhammad may peace
be upon him and his successors after him
he says when he sends an army to war to
defend themselves he says do not kill a
woman do not kill a child do not kill an
old man do not kill an animal do not cut
a tree down do not pollute their water
do not burn their homes do not invade
them at night when he was asked why you
should not invade them at night he says
so you may not wake the nursing mother
and child he says you will see those who
devoted themselves to worship God in
their own ways leave them to worship God
in their own ways that's freedom of
religion and he says fight only those
who fight you fight only those who fight
you so if you're coming to fight me I
fight you if you're not coming to fight
me you're off the hook this I mean you
know what this is now being explained in
context from the Muslims from the people
who know Islam so the politicians and
those who are out there I'm sure they're
getting a better understanding too so
they can go teach the rest of the people
the truth about Islam not the things
that they messed up probably on just you
know learning from their own and you
know
we're not going to judge their intention
but maybe they had a good intention they
just didn't know but now they know so
tell us now for someone else who says we
only got a few more points that you know
what this is when the Muslims were weak
that's why then the Muslims later they
became strong so the rules changed this
was abrogated what do you got to say
about that that is amazing because if
you go back in history you'll find out
that when Muslims were too busy
defending themselves and fighting that
propagation Islam did not flourish Islam
only flourished when was the hna was the
time that there was no war Islam
multiplied it's got so many and look at
the look at the facts the facts that
that they were when they were fighting
there were very few in numbers and when
they had the chance to actually explain
Islam without fighting without the
defense or whatever those who call
people that Islam was spread by the
sword couldn't be further from the truth
but Islam flourished from from a few
hundreds to 10,000 when they went to
open and Conquest Mecca to get it back
how did that happen with no fighting and
that's the truth and look at the uh
Indonesia is the biggest Muslim country
in the world there's not one sword that
was lifted in Indonesia and what sword
do we have now and we know that Islam is
the largest and the fastest growing
religion on the face of the Earth we
don't have any sorts we don't have any
uh the media and all that what it takes
we simply uh don't force you to become a
Muslim or not become a Muslim and the
one of the reasons The Scholar says even
if the Muslim Army is Victorious and
they put the jizya is a proof that the
Islam gives you a choice to stay on your
own religion and you simply pick pay
taxes for your life to be protected we
don't force you no compulsion religion
Allah subhana tells Prophet mamam if I
wish I would have made everyone believe
in
me do you will you compulse people to do
it and the Islam is very clear forward
to you your way to me my way we have
relayed the message the truth is is
clear and the falsehood is also clear
last closing comments and suggestions
also I mean just some more advice for
those who are out there who they want to
do the the right thing publish relations
people politicians the average person
how can they take these quranic verses
the Divine words from the creator of the
heavens and earth so they don't mess up
and take things out of context what
advice do you give for them in short
before we close don't use the cut and
paste theory for the simple fact is that
we can do the same thing and we
certainly know that that is not the
right thing to do so as again we welcome
you to come and ask us we actually
encourage you to do so and you will find
out that we all welcome you with open
arms and Open Hearts so we certainly
hope that this is an open invit
and extend that helping hand an
invitation for a friendship and
hopefully a better understanding because
we simply feel that ignorance is our
number one enemy so since we eradicate
ignorance and people will not be afraid
of what they don't know thank you very
much may God Almighty the creator of the
heavens and earth and every we say Allah
reward you in abundance for being with
us thank you very much and thank you for
sitting tight through another episode of
the dean show come back come back every
week visit us and learn more about Islam
you got to hear it put into context T
you got to hear it from the Muslims and
that's what you should be doing when you
want to know the truth about Islam come
to us sit with us eat with us go to your
local mids go to the houses of worship
you know that Islam calls you to nothing
but good Noble Behavior righteousness
developing yourself to be the best human
being that you can be and it's built on
the most important fundament that you
worship none but the creator of the
heavens and earth the same God that
Jesus Moses Abraham Noah they all
worship the one God and the last and
final messenger the prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him he came with the same
message he came with the same message
that's to worship one God do good deeds
and be the best human being that you can
be continue to come back here to Dean
show to learn more until next time peace
be unto you we know there are many
benefits to the use of black seed
according to the authentic statements of
the Prophet Muhammad peace and blessings
be upon them that's why I use the black
seed by Tes and 50% of the profits from
your order will go towards establishing
the dean Center the Masjid and mega dawa
Center use promo code the dean show for
15% off
[Music]
m